- And all I do is hold
my breath and then cry
after she's finished.
Oh my gosh, yes.
(soft rock music)
And yes, you hear people
saying just how great
your daughter is but
Simone is still Simone
and my daughter so I
don't see her or put her
on a pedestal.
(soft rock)
- Just to do the dishes.
- So if it's here turn, yes,
she needs to get out of bed
and get over there and do the dishes.
(soft rock)
- One time we were going out to dinner
and we walk out of our
rooms, wearing the exact
same outfits.
So it was like, who wore it better.
- Who wore it best.
I did.
- [Simone] Me, obviously me.
I'm like, someone has to go
change and it's not gonna be me.
So we just went to dinner
wearing the same thing.
(soft rock)
- And it was not until 2013 where she won
the world competition.
It was a very special moment,
I remember crying and crying.
- Yes, it made me tear up
'cause I got a big screen
in the arena, they'd showed
my parents and I've never
really seen my mom cry or my dad cry.
And they were sobbing up
there, I was like, Oh my God,
they're just so cute.
It just made feel so
accomplished that they're
just so proud of me that they cried.
(soft rock music)
It means the worlds just 'cause she's gone
in and out of loops for
me and she'll do anything.
She's given up so much
and sacrificed so much
for me to achieve the
things that I've achieved.
It's just amazing what she
does and what moms would do.
I am absolutely proud of my daughter.